listen what did it do hello everybody
and welcome once again to turbo dismount
let's go and see what happens
I honestly have no idea hey hey guys
welcome back to turbo dismount I
literally had no choice but to play it
again because it is so much fun it is
exactly what I love about games and burn
this game in particular it's just pure
and simple fun there's nothing else to
it
and this particular level is just going
to be amazing because there's twice the
traffic from the last one I don't even
think I need a lot of power for this one
I actually flinched
let's see it again in slow motion
oh I don't even know what the hell
actually happened here
man let's see and I come down and then I
just like expression on my face what
possible purpose with these things have
why would they exist in septic Oz oh god
that's not gonna end well
everyone please observe the proper
riding style for these precarious
scenarios to get me through what are you
gonna do when I come for you oh no a
speed bump I'm so oh wait no no you're
supposed to know I don't know it's more
ridiculous my pose or the car I'm
driving once more because I think I
found the one thing that could entertain
me for all of time and all of gaming the
only thing that will
Oh where's my body for there's pieces of
me my head that Braulio do I seriously
got a snap Braille so I'm gonna be here
all day
alright that was a slow chicken let's
see if we can get some speed going here
speed chicken go go okay well I can't
tell if you're shaking your head in the
horn I was just trying to tell you oh oh
oh boy Oh am I glad that the worst of
this ordeal is over go back and my
family was that my car as much blazing
speed as this chicken car probably has I
don't think that it's meant for this
particular level but look at me go I got
guts that's what I got
notice my awesome driving style and then
suddenly my whole body deforms and
reforms elsewhere Oh beauty it's
gorgeous
flapping my wings I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make it I'm
gonna make it I'm gonna make why are you
just following my dorsal alright now as
you can see I'm expertly coming down the
ramp and I'm about to meet my oncoming
doom
there are sales - between two of them oh
well there goes my tours owed my head in
my thigh and my arm and there the hand
went somewhere I don't know and then
there's my leg and there's my other arm
before arbres I don't know what this is
is probably burn to the carpet there's
another piece I think that might be the
most destructive impact I've ever done
and on that note I must end it because I
want to save why I brought gonna say I'm
really gonna play more but I want to
save like sub because I I so badly want
to play with this with Bob cuz this
would be so much fun anyway thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done as always I'll see you